are MRIs without contrast reliable? Well, yes and no. It depends on who you ask as far as your
oncologist. It depends on also what you're comparing to. So if I didn't MRI with contrast
I before, that's what diagnosed my cancer. If I'm doing an MRI with no contrast I know I'm not
comparing apples to apples, right? So you're comparing apples to oranges because it's not the exact same
thing. So you can't say why I'm doing so much better because, well, when Adam, it is visible without
the contrast eye. So taking it as many objective, as much objective data as you possibly can
and balancing that with my subjective data, how I'm feeling is the way you make that decision.
Understanding there is no, even though there is gold standard objective tests,
they're often incorrect. So you use the gold standards, but you understand that even as a gold
standard, it's just giving you clues. There's people that even have biopsies that are incorrect.
All that's like perfect. They're taking a tissue sample and looking at it in a lamp. Okay,
it still could have objective failure. So nothing is perfect. Nothing is perfect. So you take as many
different objective clues as possible, balance it with your subjective clues and you come to a rational
decision of where you're at in the decision making process of what you want to do for care.
To me, that's the only way to really assess how you're doing and
helping you make the decisions. Oh, can I add this back to my dieter? Can I change doing so much better?
Can I do this? And there's a lot of clues that you could do from a very non-advasive blood work.
I mean, you could get a lot of clues from just doing a complete wellness panel on our site
at a tumor marker panel, whether it's a male tumor marker panel or the female tumor marker panel.
So for 400, some bucks or something like that, you could get a lot of peace of mind in what you're doing.
So that's what I would suggest.